you and your friends are making name
cards to assign seats for dinner you
each are given an identical strip of
blank paper and begin coloring parts of
it with crayons you start with blue or
you start with blue your friend Myka
starts off with green Joelle starts with
red Holden starts with pink and Kate
starts with purple after one color is
used or after one color is used whose
strip has the same part of its area
colored as yours so let's look at my
strip right over here it has how many
equal sections well one two three four
five six equal sections and how many of
them have been colored blue well let's
see one two three four of my equal
sections have been colored blue so I
need to figure out which of these other
folks have colored exactly four six of
their strip blue and or another way of
thinking about it I want to say whoever
has an equivalent fraction colored not
blue colored whatever their color might
be so let's look first look at mica or
mica so he's got three equal sections
he's got three equal sections and he's
colored he's colored two of them two of
them green now is four six and two
thirds the same thing well he has three
equal sections I had six if I were to
group each of these each of these into
groups of two so if I were to divide by
two let me do that if I were to divide
by two so I'm going to group this into
groups of two then I would have one two
so I'd have one two three equal sections
and then if I were to group the blue the
blue strips into groups of two then I
would have one two of them that have
actually been colored blue so if I
divide both the numerator and the
denominator by 2 I get two thirds which
is the exact same fraction as mica
another way to think about it is if you
divided each of mica sections into two
so if you divided this into two this
into two and this into - well then how
many total sections does he have well
he had three now each of them each of
those three are have been divided into
two so we can multiply by 2 to get 6 so
this is multiplying by 2 and each of the
2 in green there now each of those
sections have have now been divided into
two so you can multiply by 2 as well and
you get and you get you get 4 so 2/3 + 4
6 are the same thing so Mika has colored
in the same amount that I have now let's
see whether any of these other fractions
are the same so Joelle has colored in 4
has colored in 4 out of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
4 out of 7 so it's not clear to me that
we can change this we can somehow
multiply and divide the new or or divide
the numerator and the denominator here
remember has to be about the same number
in order to not change the value at the
fraction to somehow make that equal to
4/6 she's she's colored in the same
number but the size of each of her
strips is different so 4/7 is definitely
different than 4 6 so we can rule Joelle
out Holden has colored in Holden his
colored in 3 out of 5 sections three out
of five sections once again not obvious
that I can multiply both the numerator
and denominator 3/5 times something to
get you to force it to get you to 4 6 so
these aren't equivalent and then Kate
has colored in Kate has colored in 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 8 out of 11 and once again I
could try to get a numerator up here for
I could divide by 2 but then if I divide
by 2 in the denominator I'm going to get
something strange I'm going to get 4
over 11 divided by 2 which 11 divided by
2 is like 5.5 so this is clearly not the
same thing as 4 6 so I'll rule this out
as well so mica and I have colored in
the same amount